all right now you stand there
and i will be here and when she returns
i will whisper what you must say there
no
yes i will feed you the words it's
madness how could it possibly work
do not ruin this again
[Music]
the genesis of the project was that
erica schmidt adapted the original
rostan play as a musical and i saw
kind of workshop production at the good
speed theatre in connecticut
i was commissioned to do an adaptation
of the roof stand
uh sierra no to bergerac it was to be a
musical and i cast haley bennett as
roxanne and peter dinklage as cyrano and
we did the show and joe wright came and
saw it and said
i would like to make a film of your
adaptation of cyrano and i'll direct it
and you'll write the screenplay
and i thought that was totally insane
and
i couldn't quite i you know i didn't i
work in theater i had no idea
joe had previously directed some
incredible love stories and adaptations
pride and prejudice atonement and i
thought he would bring incredible vision
if it were to be made into
a film and so erica and joe worked for
two years
on the script
roxanne
roxanne
who's there
speechless christian
i must talk to you
i'd rather read your letters i've always
loved the
the play the original and i guess it
spoke to me in terms of it being a story
about feeling
worthy of love the casting of pete in
the role of cyrano modernizes it
immediately the famous balcony scene it
involves christian standing below the
balcony of where roxanne lives they're
speaking to each other and and cyrano
speaks on behalf of christian from
behind a pillar but this plays out
through a song one of the most classic
scenes from the original rosten but it
plays out as this beautiful duet i could
no more stop loving you i could no more
stop loving you then i could stop the
sun rising then i can stop the sun
rising
really
my cruel love has never stopped growing
in my soul from the day it was born
there from the day it was born
there there
i love the rose stand but you always see
a actor wear a large fake nose and i
felt like there was something else
underneath that that i was really
interested in how we all feel like we're
not worthy of love and there's something
sort of ugly underneath it i really
wanted to do a sierra no with no nose
erica originally didn't write it for me
and my size i think the point of it is
anybody could play sierra now yes i do
have a built-in difference
that i could relate to in terms of
feeling less than
the person you love or feeling unworthy
but i think what the movie speaks to is
everybody knows that feeling
i also was really interested in the
character of roxanne because she's in a
kind of
societal cage of what is allowed to a
woman in the time that she's in and
she's really kind of pushing it to the
brink but she just doesn't want to
submit she wants everything she wants
titanic sized romantic love and she
wants it so badly that she's willing to
believe something that isn't possible
roxanne my love for you is so powerful
roxanne my love for you is so powerful
it has strangled the two serpents it is
strangled the two serpents
pride and doubt
why do you speak so halting me
rostant was quite poking fun at roxanne
for being someone that
wanted a rich intellectual life he
called roxanna procuse
which is kind of a silly woman kind of
precious so i really wanted her to feel
like a woman that i recognized a woman
that i recognized in myself and that i
thought modern women could also relate
to
roxanne's desire for education and
intellectual enrichment is actually
historically of the time women were just
beginning to
try and assert themselves through
literature in particular
i tried to create a period somewhere
between 1640 to 1712. i wanted to have a
kind of very baroque feeling by which i
mean a kind of outlandish romantic
atmosphere to the piece that then kind
of breaks down and becomes more more
simple as the story
unfolds a lot of research went into it
my designer sarah greenwood and i spent
many days pouring over paintings from
the period sarah greenwood and i have
worked together for 25 years now the
whole thing about roxanne the story we
were telling with her apartment was that
they had no money they'd have money for
bread and this feeling that family had
owned something more and the money had
gone we wanted it to feel like although
it was a grand palazzo she was living in
just a part of it and it was getting
smaller and smaller what was so
important was
to get again roxanne's character into
which really is just a balcony with
nothing there so we put on some small
little plants and we put rosemary in the
plants and they were very delicate
wildflowers some of the work they did
and they're the details it makes it so
much easier for the for the performer to
step into a space and believe the
circumstances when the details are
strong we went to this incredible i mean
there are so many incredible palazzos
everywhere but in noto we went to this
one caste lucia palazzo it's not like a
museum there's something it's much more
personal than that we built sets within
the bigger rooms and then kind of
incorporating the balcony into the suite
of rooms so it's complicated fiddly
you're in a very beautiful architectural
space that you've got to respect and
protect
this is impossible oh it's working keep
going are you going to answer my
question
my speech seems halting
because in this darkness my words must
stumble to your ear
what are you doing
my words have no such difficulty your
words fall mine must climb and perhaps i
should come down to you
no no the love triangle between syrian
or christian and roxanne is probably one
of the original love triangles and and
this one is just as exciting just as
classy just as funny and just as
heartbreaking these characters love
tortures them but it's not cynical it's
a real throwback
to a real heart on your sleeve sort of
feeling that i think people still go to
the movies for and i thought it has
everything in common with what we live
in today because
look at these dating websites basically
that's what
sierna was doing with christian to get
roxanne's love he was setting up a false
profile of himself
i like this way of talking
i like being invisible to each other
i cannot be stunned into silence by your
beauty
here in this awkwardness i am free at
last to speak
from my heart
the way i feel is like
falling stars
diving into cold
ocean waves
words can only get
me so far
but they cannot describe
the way
that it hurts all the singing in the
movie was recorded live the actors would
have an earpiece in which they'd hear a
pre-recorded instrumental track or
sometimes actually the live pianist
playing and then we recorded their
singing as they did it on set within the
scene you really get the sense of the
moment the emotion the exhaustion the
longing
what is it you're so afraid of
losing
that i might lose everything if i
lose the pain
because every time i see
you
i am
overcome
[Music]
it make him have to think someone like
me could keep someone like you
look what i've become
i wanted to strip back rostan's language
so that
the words that were chosen
for love were really spare and really
evocative and felt more like modern
songs than you know high romantic poetry
the music was composed by aaron and
bryce desner and the lyrics were written
by matt behringer and karen besser of
whom i've been a big fan for many years
it was a challenge for matt and corinne
to write the words
to a song that plays out as a dialogue
between a hidden voice and roxanne and
the balcony you want to write a fully
formed song but also you want something
that that for the actor is really just
an occasion to kind of get closer more
intimate and and listen to them saying
we wanted to have a reason there must be
some emotion that's welling up so much
that it's
breaking conversation into song and so
trying to write lyrics that were
emotionally
potent and genuine and sincere you wore
your hair down one time last spring
in the chapel
your lips painted red
i remember
the day
we hadn't met yet how could you possibly
remember
that
you watched me then
why didn't
you say something
because every time i see you
i am
[Music]
overcome
they have a lot of interesting things
about their voices for instance peter
dinklage is a stage actor and he's used
to singing to the back of the room but
in a film way because the microphones
could be close
he could sing quietly he could sing
softly he could sing to himself that was
very interesting for him to discover the
quieter sides of his voice
haley bennett there's something very
pure about her voice she can push it to
a pop place and or she can have these
sort of very pure almost flute like
tones
calvin harrison jr is a phenomenal
musician and he really made the songs
his own singing live is tough
but there's certain things that you
can't do in a studio that you can do on
set when you're sitting there and i'm
looking into peter's eyes and i'm
connecting with him it's so different
from standing in front of a mic and
singing it it was an extremely daunting
prospect but it was important to joe
that the music not feel manufactured
it's something that's coming from your
soul rather than
just lip singing
it's also built around guitar playing my
brother and i have always done this kind
of interlocking patterns that are we'll
play like an eighth note or a 16th note
off each other and we're able to do it
because we're twins and we grew up
playing this way but it almost sounds
kind of like lattice work
[Music]
it's one of my favorite musical moments
in the film joe wright has a very
emotional response to music which is
good because i think that
is sort of what we do well it's really
it's kind of difficult to describe i
said modern folk really and i think that
gives the singing a kind of intimacy and
humanness especially because of the
actors recorded their singing as they
did it on set within the scene it also
means you get little kind of faults in
the voices as well little crack or a
little breath or breath in the wrong
place and i feel that that
makes them
you know heartbreaking i try to tell you
tell you how much i need you to
look what i've become
nothing feels real anymore when you're
not around me
even the sky looks like it's behind
glass
it's like live theater
it's like they're singing live and they
you forgive the scratches
you know that's part of
singing that's your soul it doesn't
matter your voice isn't as important as
what your soul is saying we were in the
middle of a pandemic and i was just
incredibly moved by that added
determination from all those involved to
create something
special in defiance of
of this terrible thing that was
happening to the world
[Music]
i'm right here love
words fail me
please come to me
i try but i can't
this is real love did you believe you'd
have me
i have no doubt
i know that you were the one now
you don't know anything
i know
that it's you
roxanne if this was true
just tell me what you need now i might
need for nothing
just tell me what to do
give me a kiss
no
yes i asked for a kiss but i was too
bold
you don't insist yes
oh be quiet
you were speaking of a kiss
yes what is a kiss
surely you know
i meant metaphorically
is it a vow a promise a confession
a secret
a moment of eternity
a communion a heartbeat
no more metaphors
come claim your kiss
literally
go there
it seems wrong now
she wants you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you